remember remember the unnecessary scene
[Music]
so I'm gonna do another nitpick ran this
one on V for Vendetta oh I should have
put this out on November 5th yeah crap
heck with it
in any case this movie I love this movie
this very sincerely this is one of my
favorite movies I find it
energizing I find it artistically made I
find it heartbreaking at times there's a
scene in it that made my list of movies
movie moments that always made me cry
I think the performances are amazing I
think the the look and the feel of the
thing is incredible the the way it it
moves it story along I think it picked
just the right parts of the original
work so I think it's a terrific example
of well-done adaptation I really like
this movie except for one scene that I
basically I'll be honest they skip it
like I hit the skip chapter button
whenever I watch this thing and that is
the Rookwood scene now this particular
nitpick will qualify as spoilers so be
aware of that if you haven't seen the
movie already but that's also kind of
the problem with this scene because what
this scene does is it lays out stuff
that anybody paying attention could have
already figured out or at the very least
had a very strong suspicion of and so
it's got an inherent problem where it's
making clear something that I really
would have preferred they they trust the
audience to get on their own because
what the whole scene is is it is this
character who is apparently a former
government official who's currently in
hiding named Brookwood giving
information to a police inspector who's
investigating all this stuff going on
about how the government came to power
and it included amongst other things a
manufactured terrorist attack and and
that you know that and how that lined up
with specific characters in figures in
the government who we have seen and of
course the head of the whole thing so
all of this gets laid out by this
character of Rookwood and it's first of
all as I said it's not entirely
necessary because most of this is stuff
that we could either infer or actually
doesn't matter so like for example the
this kind of shakes the the police
detective because he it makes him
question you know the the folks that are
in authority except he's got a lot of
reason to do that already and it isn't
necessary to sell how evil this
government is we've been watching them
we've been watching these figures what
they do what they authorized like the
the scene that I I put on my sad moments
list you know the scene of of Evie
jailed and communicating with the
prisoner next to her that seems way more
effective at outlining the atrocities
that this government is capable of and
adding in that they basically fake their
way into power doesn't really make them
all that much worse because how they got
into power while a horrible thing that
they did the way that they're wielding
power is also horrible so we didn't need
another reason to think that they're
horrible and like I said most of what's
in here is stuff that is it we kind of
already knew to some extent now it is
making the connections more explicitly
than the film had up to that point but
first of all I would argue in much of
the cases the details that is laying out
are necessary and B even if you don't
feel they are necessary this is a really
clunky way to do it to have a character
who
we have never seen before show up out of
nowhere sit in heavy shadows and just
dictate the back history to us for four
minutes now there's a fair amount of
exposition in this movie we like to
spread like that scene that I love
that's an exposition scene but it's
handled really well and there are other
scenes where you know we're going
through characters logs and notebooks
and we hear their narration of it you
know there's plenty of scenes of
exposition but none of them are is
boring or is forced or I have nowhere or
as in organic as this one is and then of
course there's the other problem which
is the longer work would talks the more
painfully obvious it becomes that it's
just the in disguise because we have
this guy and a hat and dart and
completely dark sunglasses and a big
beard in with at least half his face in
shadow and the more you hear him talk
because you know remember we've never
seen these face but we hear him talk a
lot so the more you hear this character
of work would talk the more you're gonna
be liable to make that connection of I
know that voice and first time I watched
this ever I caught on to that I'd say he
was about halfway through it I wasn't
enjoying the scene anyway guys like to
say it's awkward it's clunky and I have
other reasons to dislike it but the fact
that he just keeps talking talking and
talking it meant wait a minute and then
it the instant you even have the notion
you you look at the way that they're
shooting him is like oh yeah yeah that's
definitely him and so that doesn't work
as a twist or anything else it the
characters that the information is being
relayed to figure out that they were
that he wasn't who they thought he was
almost immediately so the impact that
this has on the characters that are
being told this information too is
negligible and whatever movement it does
do you could forget on another way to
get that information that wasn't this
clunky awkward stupid scene the sea
his stupid and it's so aggravating
because like I said this is a film that
does really well moments of on the
surface appearing to stop the plot in
order to give us background and it does
that phenomenally and a number of other
points but here it's so crowbarred in
and it's arrived at so unnaturally with
this guy who's come out of nowhere and
you can it's like I said super easy to
figure out what the toys with him is and
it doesn't move the plot forward it
doesn't alter the character motivation
significantly from the path that they
were already themselves actually on
there is nothing of value in the scene
and one little bit you could argue that
it gives I would say there are much
better ways to accomplish the few scant
things that it actually attempts to do
and for the most part I just skip this
thing you have a much better viewing
experience and that's why I really hate
that scene in a movie that I otherwise
have no problems with like the movies
practically perfect except for that one
friggin scene and that's just one scene
that I always skip because it drives me
nuts in a movie that I otherwise loved
so what are your thoughts on the
Rookwood scene from be for Vendetta
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all the stuff that you can do because
there's buttons and there's links and
there's things down there check about if
you're interested there's a link to the
patreon but you know if you know
whatever cool I'm not gonna pressure you
and remember folks you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]